[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Good evening.
And here are the nominees
for Best Original Song.
We really did not expect to win.
It was like finding--
I mean, just being
nominated was like finding
$20 in your pocket.
It was very nice
and very surprising
when they called our name.
When Lin said, México.
México, Kristen Anderson-Lopez
and Robert Lopez for Remember
Me.
[APPLAUSE]
The first thing I thought
is I got to hug the kids.
I'm so glad they're
here to see that.
It was really special
to have them there
and to be able to
shout out to them.
And our daughters, Katie and
Annie, who are here with us
tonight.
Your love and creativity
inspire everything we do.
We wrote Remember
Me because we're
songwriters who have to
leave our kids behind,
and we leave them little
songs that they can sing.
(SINGING) So I sing
a secret song to you
each night we are apart.
(SINGING) I sing a secret song
to you each night we are apart.
Remember Me.
We left them with lullabies so
they could feel our presence.
And so, I think there wouldn't
be the same Remember Me
without those two girls.
It's crazy, that song--
writing Remember Me.
Very shortly after we wrote
it, my grandmother passed away,
and then sadly, a few
years later, my mom
lost a battle with cancer.
And that song helped me realize
that it's through our memories
that our loved ones live on.
And there's feeling
of a family reunion
to Coco, a family reunion that
can cross the life and death
barrier.
That is a really, really
beautiful thought,
and I think that's why people
love the movie so much.
This is for my mom
who passed away.
Everyone who knew her
will always remember her.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]